[Music]
in more than an athlete's news system
submitted by Kara from Virginia Beach
LeBron James has open experimental
school for at-risk students I thought
this is pretty cool is that
I promise school where everything's paid
for there was a meme going around is
that [ __ ] great this is real have you
seen what the school looks like it looks
like like a Vegas strip bar you ever
been to Vegas strip on old town are you
the new ones like they all look like
third-world dictators mansions like that
and like Nike town had a baby yeah yeah
it's crazy world dictators cuz there's
like this one wall of his only his shoes
and all that stuff it's pretty tight Oh
Danny hasn't seen I just see him like in
a slim young yeah I just saw him in a
suit anyone looking like Louis Farrakhan
he's like an activist from the 60s or
something like that but like a like a
black Nikon Nation of Islam no come X
looking black nationalism for it though
what's the chances of those actually
being real glasses
there's II like black hipster oh those
are style glasses he doesn't these are
real man look man I mean like blind
I watched my porn rune my dude when I do
porn I go in Junko like this close I
used to do a lot of coke and we just go
on those deep porn dives and I'd stop
watching the enforcer
I said I would used to do a lot but you
got the whole building yeah dude you
probably built that like it's like 50
million dollars or something for the
whole thing you got a deal from Nike a
lifetime contract for a billion dollars
him him and Ronaldo Wow a lifetime
contract billion dollars so what if he
gets hurt or sick what means for the
rest of his life he's represented by
Nike yeah it's like it's like the Jordan
thing he saw iconic now that it doesn't
even matter if he's healthy or not no I
don't even over and although was that
Ronaldo had a [ __ ] deal like that
that guy's good that guy was probably
Schindler in his last life saved a bunch
of Jews during [ __ ] the Holocaust and
now it's like the best looking guy needs
a grace happily yeah blasted him it's
cool I must have been a scumbag in my
past line me too I'm repeating it again
I gotta do something bad don't go into
light dude that's the key that's the
archons they want you go back and that's
a whole different thing brah I promise
you though that focuses on accelerated
learning it provides job placement
assistant for parents once a week tennis
dope Oh cuz that's true because
sometimes when the kids need help it's
usually because the parents are stupid
as [ __ ] and they can't get shot so
that's why you need to send the whole
family
you send the whole family to school yeah
and they also have on-site Food Bank oh
that is so cool yeah no they also teach
parents like how to create meals at home
so we could have a nice healthy meal
that's cool for sure man I mean it's
awesome people always want to talk
sexism racism all this other stuff but
the biggest indicator of how well your
life's gonna be isn't what race all
right it's your intelligence
yeah you know if you're I'm care if
you're white or whatever if you're dumb
you're gonna
a hard [ __ ] life well what about if
you're hot and dumb well that is
different see we can't say that but it's
very short-lived choices start dating
idiots and stuff like that or you just
picture LeBron is how like what how come
you can't afford a full pants it stops
like halfway down his ankles that's
tying it up right now it's not so much
folding it up it's like the leg breaks
different now so like depending on what
time so literally like 10 years ago the
leg break was right above the heel he
used to work at Men's Wearhouse yes I
love suits so like the leg break is
typically above the shoe that's where we
had it when we've had back in the day
yeah now it's a bright about the ankle
same thing Sydney with suits so we have
before we was at the cuff some people
like it a little longer so like [ __ ]
because I like clothes and fashion but
I'm really sweaty like just thing as
cool as possible tej time you ever go to
Vegas like the women all dressed like
they're going to Oscars guys all dressed
like they're going to bed like they're
just about to take a nap especially the
poker table yeah they look like they
come to Vegas and pajamas guys just want
to relax when we just want to doll it up
yeah except at 3:00 a.m. all the girls
have their shoes off and they looked
like a mess yeah all right more of
LeBrons I promise cool they're saying
that it supports students with stress
from economic causes gives every student
a bike on their first day of school to
escape dangerous parts of town and
explore because that's what LeBron did
when he was a kid this time he's like if
you're on foot you can't run that fast
but if you're on a bike you might be
able to outrun the jackers yeah I had a
bike that's a target for it exactly my
bike got stolen yeah it's gonna give a
bike in some LeBron James they're gonna
get mugged in like a [ __ ]
these are biking shoes yeah I asked for
a shitty bike like one that works good
but the tires all [ __ ] up but it's the
heads up like that wouldn't they look at
there like I feel sorry for you and then
the gangsters want to give me charity
that's the kind of bike I want you
should just teach these kids karate so
you could beat the [ __ ] out of everybody
lessons like math and Quran yeah that
sounds like a Asian after-school program
I wish a [ __ ] would school
that's right
it's self-defense in math skills yeah so
they also say that I guarantees free
college tuition to the University of
Akron to all graduates starting 2021 I
think it's great Oh what is it what how
does that work though and how words like
the consistent funding coming from
LeBron and sponsors yeah sure yeah
sponsors is foundation got billion
dollars from Nike oh I'm doing that bad
that's amazing
why did it take this long I feel for I I
don't I do feel for MBA I for pro
athletes there is this thing that they
have to help the community more than any
other ethnic group I feel like they have
to go back and build these schools and
do all that stuff and it's a lot more
pressure on them to just always be
political always be involved in that
stuff and it it's like you don't see
that when any other group okay I don't
see it in UFC I don't say well they
don't get the kind of money on money but
I don't I don't yeah that's true I don't
really see it and but particularly black
athletes have to like go back and help
the black community more than I've ever
seen any other ethnic group well I mean
like the you know Derrick Rose just
start a giant scholarship fund I mean
you see it a lot and you know does it
though Latin baseball players do a lot
for their oh they do thanks to that yeah
they bring it back yeah that's true
maybe cuz a lot of the athletes came
from nothing so they feel like a social
responsibility to kind of like help
others where if you came from middle
class then you don't have that mentality
maybe I don't know that's true one of
our friends the one thing he went out
but he's our friends friend but it's
kind of I've been to his house just
start over
he's a friend okay come on best friend
no wall Dane he's from Sudan yeah so he
has basketball camps specifically for
Sudanese people and I think it's just
because that's where he came on yet so
he wants to just help and and uplift his
community had a great year last year
right collected checks didn't have to
play a game yeah I felt bad for me all
day man they ran him into the [ __ ]
ground
no yeah do Rama the [ __ ] ground no
[ __ ] respected he was dope dude I'm
such a waste
yeah I mean well that's time Timmy look
who he's doing with the Minnesota
Timberwolves he's just running him into
ground that's not that idiot did yeah
he's old school and old we always say
coach is old school that's a code word
for an [ __ ] they [ __ ] ran the wall
Dane to the ground dude he had like this
I can't remember but it's some kind like
spinal tap he had like some issue which
it wasn't even the problem here like the
flu and it [ __ ] him up and he still
played after it and just yeah this
program is pretty dope because it
reminds me of one of the things that me
and Bart actually wanted to do for our
community but the opposite of what what
what's happening here so like like most
people want to want to help kids get
like tutoring help math help we already
have that [ __ ] like way too much in the
asian community too much [ __ ] math
right we're trying to do the opposite is
like how do you have fun with life
school I teach kids like music music
[ __ ] [ __ ] we need that learn how to
be a [ __ ] up yeah how do you give up
something like being a doctor and Hut
like throw away your chances and do
something fun that's the kind of scary
asian living room is already a tutoring
center yeah so we don't the last thing
we need is more math help or English
help or whatever we need to know the
more instruments like piano and [ __ ]
yeah let's teach them guitar drums I
feel like I think the Asian community
does it right though I mean like the
white people just want to be there kids
best friends like they just want to
write they want to be like a crew runner
like [ __ ] that fun it's like can i
[ __ ] your mom tonight
sure daddy you know so it's just like
know you're there to teach them life
skills yeah
is it is there a difference though like
conservative and liberal right like
there's like the conservative old-school
white folks still have that kind of
hierarchy and and then the kids are
still like there's that family hierarchy
basically but then the liberal side is
like the the extreme form of like no
don't call me mom call me bhai whatever
yeah yeah yeah call me Valerie yeah yeah
all the news we're the Los Feliz Echo
Park Silver Lake parents there it's
different breed now because I almost see
it as like when I don't is it's so hard
for me to see as like one culture like
when I see white white people it's not
like one group you know I mean because
even within white people there there's
the right in the left and I already see
that as two different cultures like
completely different one is like super
conservative Christian and old-school
and then the other is like trying to
figure out what kind of gender their kid
is and they don't want to do a gender
reveal party because they think that's a
baby or whatever and I feel like people
live today to try to find more problems
within the song God these are too good
let's look for more problems you know I
mean it's like bro I just think about
these college kids they go to school and
they just they just love outrage more
than everything like I went to college
to just drink and get laid did my credit
was [ __ ] I just didn't even care
that's what the normal college life like
man I go to Berkeley man every day
there's a riot over words and they don't
allow speakers to come it's like what a
horrible you are you are wasting the
best years your life college is the best
time you just I mean it's like being a
rapper you're just drinking and [ __ ]
and sure that's true that's like four
years of anger yeah what why would you
waste your time on being sad for four
years and angry and if you're not angry
about something you're you're ignorant
it's a mess I feel like white people are
the most manipulated by the media
and pop culture like white guys watch
too many romantic comedies and they just
think women want guys to write poems and
do all that dumb ass [ __ ] right y'all
[ __ ] knuckle draggers write knuckle
dragger like just [ __ ] goons dude
right just like dudes or dudes and like
white guys all just want to wear [ __ ]
like pink hats on their head and [ __ ]
cry about injustice nobody bunch of
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]